hello hello congratulations guys hey
thanks Perry how are you doing how are
you I am doing really well always good
to see you so my first question is for
both of you because our production notes
focused a whole lot on the fact that you
tried out different voices for these
characters while trying to find the
right one so to give us a sense of how
much you were able to play can you each
tell me the two most polar opposite
ideas that you explored for the voices
for these two characters before settling
on what we see in the finished film I
mean entirely in French I was like you
know the illumination you're in France
why don't I do this all in French and
they said do you speak French is it not
really yeah and they said yeah that's
not going to stop it's not going to work
for us doing a super stereotypical
French accent it says it sounds
fringe-ish yeah and they say are you
saying a French accent I'm like no so
french-ish words
you know No One's Gonna know what that
is I speak french-ish so I would have
gotten it yeah
yeah they shot that right down
um yeah I mean I I gosh I don't know
that I had like big wide uh choices that
were all that different that what ended
up it was a little bit more
um you know slightly nuanced the the
differences uh
we tried a few different things and then
ultimately took probably three or four
sessions before settling on what worked
and uh once we had that figured out they
would you know I'd go to the session
they would play back the The Hit List of
like the 15 or 20 phrases that they had
that were like this is the voice this is
where we want it to be and so once we
did that it would be like like a little
tuning horn or something called tuning
horn yeah a fork tuning fork or like one
of those things
harmonica yeah his he's the he grew up
in a musical family
um yeah
um this is probably the most serious
question you're gonna hear all day but
one of my favorite parts of this movie
was how Luigi is there to support
Mario's goals and Ambitions when others
will not so in your careers who is your
Luigi the person who you know if you
have a big crazy dreamer idea in this
business is always there to get behind
it and help you with it oh wow my real
brother in my real life life was
definitely that for me like he has
always believed in me always thought
that I was going to go and do
extraordinary things even when I didn't
have belief in myself he would be the
one who's like you're cut out for this
this is you're meant to do this you're
special you have it trust me you could
do this so he was always like that guy
who who yeah and preventing love that's
my wife for me you know I I direct this
movie Fool's Paradise coming on May 12th
May 12th um and uh and I think she's
regretted on it because like every
decision I would
think about that for many many years in
the making of that so uh yeah she's been
a good partner in that regard I love
that so much I love the quotes you gave
about Guillermo del Toro's help too he's
one of my favorite people in the
business so to know how he helped you on
that it just fills my heart truly it
goes my wife
Guillermo just just right out of there
yeah correct list there yeah something
else here's my one selfish question
during this interview because Chris I'm
sorry I'm just obsessed with Jurassic
and I know you said that that franchise
has come to an end for you but having
been in that world for so long if they
were to make another movie or a show
whether you're involved or not is there
any particular corner of that world that
you would like to see either further
explored or explored for the first time
maybe wow that's such a it's such a
great question I would say just with
given the Advent of what we can now do
underwater I'm curious to see more about
the Mosasaur I thought that dinosaur was
like uh was was a wonderful creature but
I'd be curious a little bit more about
the life of that fabulous creature maybe
some more underwater dinosaurs what
about dancing you know like there's not
enough dancing in those did the
dinosaurs dance and can we explore the
World of Dance you know once one time
James Gunn gave me a picture he was like
he was like what about cavemen isn't
there like a caveman version of the
Jurassic thing where like a caveman like
like the remake of Iceman or something
like that where like maybe the DNA they
extract is I don't know yeah
that's when I knew that he was never
gonna go anywhere with his career I've
been watching an Encino Man Jurassic
mashup any day would that be so good oh
my God man yeah and bring Brendan Fraser
back and Pauly Shore that's right I'm
pretty sure we just came up with a
genius idea that someone needs to pay us
for now yes thank you that's that would
be really good all right I must leave
you guys huge congratulations on this
one and thanks for your time today thank
you